JILLIAN, IT DIDN’T WORK AND IT
COST HIM $13 BILLION OVER TO
YOU, JILLIAN.
JILLIAN: ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ LENDING HER VOICE
AS SO-CALLED SQUAD JOINS CALLS
TO CANCEL RENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
>> RIGHT NOW AT A TIME WHEN SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE -- LIVES ARE
THREATENED BY A PANDEMIC, THEIR
LIVES SHOULDN’T ALSO BE
THREATENED BY THE FEAR OF
EVICTION, BY THE FEAR OF
FORECLOSURE OR WORSE.
JILLIAN: IS THIS THE ANSWER?
RIGHT RESPONSE?
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST ERIN
ELMORE.
SEEING YOU FOR A SECOND TIME
THIS MORNING.
WELCOME BACK.
>> THANK YOU.
JILLIAN: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
RICHARD, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
JILLIAN: IT’S FAIR A LOOKOUT OF
PEOPLE CAN’T PAY THEIR RENT OR
MORTGAGE AT THE FIRST OF THE
MONTH RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO NEED HELP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE ANSWER?
>> WELL, THIS WILL BE THE SECOND
MONTH THAT WE HAVE GONE SINCE
THE CORONAVIRUS FOLK HAVE HAD TO
PAY RENT.
THIS CREATES A REAL PROBLEM FOR
A LOT OF RENTERS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
THIS ALSO CREATES A PROBLEM FOR
ALAN LORDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
RENTERS ARE DEALING WITH NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY RENT.
LAND LORDS ARE DEALING WITH THE
REALITY OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
MAKE MORTGAGES, NOT BEING ABLE
TO MAKE REMAYOR PAIRS.
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT SOME WAY TO PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORRIED, WHO ARE ANXIOUS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PAY MAY’S
RENT AND JUNE’S RENT.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
DO THIS AND DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
JILLIAN: THINKING ABOUT THIS I
WAS A HOMEOWNER THE LAST 14
YEARS UP UNTIL FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR I SOLD MY HOUSE.
I HAD TENANTS IN THERE FOR A
LONG TIME.
I WAS SITTING THERE THINKING IF
THEY CAME TO ME AND SAID I CAN’T
PAY MY RENT THIS MONTH.
ULTIMATELY THAT FALLS BACK ON ME
AND THEN I HAVE TO BE THE ONE TO
DEAL WITH TRYING TO CALL MY
MORTGAGE COMPANY, SEE IF THEY
CAN HELP ME.
SO THE BRUNT OF THIS IS GOING
SOMEWHERE.
IT IS FALLING ON SOMEONE’S
SHOULDERS.
>> RIGHT.
I DON’T THINK AOC REALIZES THAT
WE’RE NOT DEALING WITH BIG BANKS
HERE.
WE’RE DEALING WITH LANDLORDS.
AND THEY NEED TO PAY THEIR BILLS
AND THEY NEED TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES.
I COULDN’T AGREE WITH MR. FOWLER
MORE WHICH PROBABLY DOESN’T
HAPPEN THAT OFTEN ALTHOUGH I
LIKE HIM VERY MUCH.
AOC ALTHOUGH SHE IS
ENVIRONMENTALIST.
I THINK SHE BELIEVES THAT MONEY
GROWS ON TREES.
EVERYONE HAS OBLIGATIONS RIGHT
NOW.
LOOK, WE HAVE 30.3 MILLION
AMERICANS OUT OF WORK IN THE
LAST SIX WEEKS.
THERE IS A TRAGEDY GOING ON
HERE.
THERE IS A CRISIS IN AMERICA.
AND HER IDEAS DON’T SEEM TO HAVE
ANY SOLUTIONS AND ARE NOT
GROUNDED IN REALITY IN ANY WAY
WHATSOEVER.
JILLIAN: RICHARD, WE LIKE YOU,
TOO.
YOU HAVE AN OP-ED -- JUST TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR, HAVE YOU AN
OP-ED ON FOXNEWS.COM RIGHT NOW
IT SAYS THAT THE STIMULUS WILL H
MILLENNIALS THE MOST, WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT?
>> WHAT THAT OP-ED IS TALKS
ABOUT WHY WE AS A CONSIDER
SHOULD CONSIDER THE IDEA OF
FORGIVING STUDENT LOAN DEBT UP
TO A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
HERE’S WHAT WE KNOW.
WE KNOW FOR THE AVERAGE STUDENT
LOAN BORROWER MAKES ABOUT
$48,000 A YEAR.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEY SPEND
ABOUT 10% OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME DEALING WITH STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN A
FEDERALLY SUPPLIED FEDERALLY
BACKED LOAN.
WE ARE REALLY THINKING ABOUT
PRIMING THIS ECONOMY, THE TRICK
WE HAVE SEEN FROM THE GREAT
DEPRESSION TO THE GREAT
RECESSION IS YOU HAVE GOT TO
MAKE THE MIDDLE AND LOWER PARTS
OF THE ECONOMY WORK.
AND THEY HAVE GOT TO ROAR.
THOSE FOLKS TO TO-TO-HAVE
LIQUIDITY.
FORGIVING $10,000 OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT OR LESS FOR THESE
STUDENTS FOR THESE FOLKS ADULTS
PART OF OUR SOCIETY.
WHO WORK IN OUR RESTAURANTS.
WHO WORK IN OUR LOCAL BARS.
WHO WORK AT OUR LOCAL RETAILERS.
THEE NEED SOME RELIEF.
GIVING THEM THIS 10% BACK WOULD
CREATE AUTOMATIC LIQUIDITY INTO
THE ECONOMY AND ALLOW THEM TO
GOUT AND MAKE PURCHASES, TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILY AND
POSSIBLY PAY THEIR RENT.
JILLIAN: ERIN, FINAL WORD TO
YOU?
>> I THINK WE DO A DEFERRAL.
WE CAN’T CANCEL BECAUSE WHERE IS
THAT MONEY GOING TO COME FROM?
IF YOU MADE THE OBLIGATION TO
PAY SOMETHING.
YOU OWE THAT MONEY AND THAT’S
JUST THE AMERICAN WAY.
DEFER IT FOR SIX MONTHS.
I’M TOTALLY OKAY WITH THAT
UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY
PAID FOR THEIR COLLEGE.
WHEN YOU SPEND MONEY, YOU GOT TO
PAY IT BACK.
JILLIAN: GO AHEAD, RICHARD, REAL
QUICK.
10 SECONDS.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING WITH THE
PAY CHECK PROTECTION LOANS IF
COMPANIES ARE ACTUALLY PAYING
WORKERS, THEIR LOANS ARE
FORGIVEN BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WHY NOT EXTEND THAT SAME BENEFIT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
MILLIONS OF THEM THAT HAVE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
THIS IS ABOUT PUMPING OUR
ECONOMY.
THIS IS A DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN PROBLEM.
IT’S A AN AMERICAN PROBLEM.
STUDENT LOAN CRISIS IS REAL.
WE CAN SOLVE IT SLOWLY BY DOING
JUST THIS ONE MEASURE.
JILLIAN: WELL, A LOT OF THINGS
ARE REAL RIGHT NOW FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE SOME MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
OUT OF JOBS RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE ALL JUST TRYING TO FIND